[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: I want
to thank all of you
for being here with us tonight.
Well, it's true that Google's
putting a lot of effort
into the developments that
you've just heard about.
Flutter is an
open-source project.
And it's created and supported
by an entire community
of SDK contributors, package
developers, YouTube creators,
and more.
And by choosing to
join us tonight,
you're now part
of that community.
And we want to hear your voice.
So for the next
hour or so, we're
answering your questions
live right here.
You can post them in the
YouTube livestream comments
or tweet using the
#AskFlutter hashtag,
and we'll get to
as many as we can.
So you're working
the streams, Wm.
We get a lot of
questions so far?
WM LELER: Oh my god.
Yes.
We have a ton of questions, and
we've been getting about two
per second now, which is down
from the high of about seven
per second.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
WM LELER: So, yeah.
We're getting a lot of tweets.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cool.
We also have a
few drop-in guests
lined up from the
Flutter engineering team.
And we're coming to you from
the crowd at Flutter Live.
So if you ask a
question I can't handle,
I'll find somebody that can and
we'll get them up here with me
and answer it together.
So, all right.
Wm, are we ready to go?
WM LELER: Well, let's
start with an obvious one.
We've been getting
a lot of questions--
actually, even
before the keynote,
we were getting so
many people asking us,
when are Maps going to
be available on Flutter?
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: Now we already have
the answer to that question,
but let's go into it
a little bit deeper.
Can you give us a
little demo of how
Maps are working on Flutter?
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
Yeah.
So, full disclosure,
we kind of figured
this one was definitely coming.
So I've got some stuff
ready to go on my laptop.
Real quick, let's take
a look at the code.
So one of the nice
things-- you know,
Flutter is completely
open source-- the SDK,
the tools, the language.
You know, Dart itself
is open source,
and the plugins are, too.
So let's go to our plugins repo.
So this is flutter/plugins.
Got it up on my laptop.
And if you go in here, you can
see a bunch of the packages
that the team is maintaining
and building out.
There's stuff for battery,
camera, connectivity
and things.
And way down here we have
Google Maps for Flutter.
And so if you're ever curious
about this code base--
you know, what can
Maps do right now,
where's it going-- this is a
great place to go check out.
So we have the lib directory,
which has the imports.
This will have the
Google Map widget.
Because this is Flutter.
Everything's a widget.
It also has the map controller
and some other things.
And then we have the Android
and iOS sort of bridge
that goes from Dart
into the Google Maps
SDKs for Android and iOS.
And let's see what
code I've got here.
So, here we have our
DevRel sample for Maps.
And this was done by
the very talented Kenzie
Schmoll up at our Portland
office, who you know well.
And this is right
now up on GitHub
in the flutter/samples repo.
That's the one that DevRel
uses for our samples.
So all this code you
can go get right now.
And let's take a
look at this app.
So this is using a
Google Map widget.
And it does the
things you'd kind of
expect a Google Map to do.
You can pan around,
you can zoom in.
She's got some places that
she's added to this map.
She's got a couple sets.
And you can see if I
switch between them
the map automatically zooms
out, just like you'd expect.
I can go in here and switch
terrain types, for example.
I can check that, go
from the Street View
to satellite, topographic
if you want to know
where the mountains are.
You can even turn it off.
And then back to Street View.
And as you notice, I'm
clicking on buttons on the map
that you wouldn't normally
see on the Google Map.
And that's because
they're Flutter widgets.
These are things that
Kenzie added to this on top
using a stack.
WM LELER: So the Map
widget, it's just
a widget like any other widget.
ANDREW BROGDON:
It's just a widget.
It's doing some
things under the hood,
but it's still just a widget.
You saw in the demo
that [? Philip ?] did,
he even threw it
into a transform,
and his map was
tilted like this.
You can play with
them just like that.
So, speaking of
playing with it, let's
mess with this a little bit.
WM LELER: Yeah.
I wanted to ask.
How hard is it to add
Maps, then, to your app?
ANDREW BROGDON: So
a good way to answer
that question would be to just
blow away this entire app.
WM LELER: OK.
Let's kill it.
ANDREW BROGDON: So this is home.
I'm going to replace
everything in the app with just
a Google Map.
So let's try that.
Here's the Google Map widget.
And the map, its
constructor takes
a single required parameter,
which is onMapCreated.
And this is a little callback.
So to interact with the map,
you use a Google Map controller.
The controller pattern you
may have seen elsewhere
in Flutter, the text fields
and some of the inputs.
This is how you interact
with it, change its behavior.
And so it has a little
callback that'll
give you the controller.
And so I'm just going to
make a spot to hold it.
So I'll go up here, make a
little Google Map controller,
just like that.
And I'll call it _mapController.
And I'm going to
assign that down here.
All right, so I've got
my widget in place,
I've got the
controller callback.
Let's do a little hot reload.
And there we go.
So my entire app now is
basically just a map.
And I can still come
in here and do things.
If I wanted to zoom in,
I can click and zoom.
I can still pan around
and things like that.
All right.
So let's do something with this.
We've got the map, we've
got the controller.
WM LELER: Well, you said
before you could add buttons
over the Flutter widget--
the Map widget.
Let's see what we can do.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
Let's add a button and
we can do something.
We click the button.
So I'll wrap this in,
let's go with a stack.
So I'll put this in a stack.
And of course stacks
have children rather than
a single child, so we add that.
And that's going to be a list.
Come down here.
The magic of auto-formatting.
And let's put a button.
And I'm going to want this--
I'll put this in the
lower left-hand corner,
just so we know where it
is, so use a Positioned.
There we go.
So bottom, I'll give
it a little padding.
That's not how you
spell "bottom."
And left.
Maybe a little padding there.
And then child.
I'll give this a RaisedButton.
And so our button
will need some text.
Let's move the camera when
the button gets put, I'd say.
How about that?
There we go.
And we'll give it an onPressed,
because every button needs
an onPressed callback if
it's going to be used.
And just for fun,
let's give it a color.
Let's give it a-- is there
a light green material spec?
There is a light green.
Awesome.
OK.
Let's hot reload again.
We've still got our map.
And let's-- we've
got a button now.
Let's move the camera
when we get this click.
So we have the controller.
And, update-- animateCamera.
Let's do an animative--
WM LELER: OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: And that's
going to take a CameraUpdate.
And then we'll do--
let's do a LatLng here.
Do you happen to know any
latitudes and longitudes?
WM LELER: How about for London?
ANDREW BROGDON: Do
you know London?
WM LELER: I sure do.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
WM LELER: It's 51.5 latitude
and, well, let's just say 0.
That's actually Greenwich,
but it's close by.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
I'm going to put a semi-colon
on there, and-- oh, wait.
That gets a comma.
WM LELER: Do you want to
zoom in a little bit, too?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
All right.
So come over here.
Let's zoom in a little.
Oh.
It twisted.
And let's go ahead
and save this.
So we're hot reloading again.
And let me click
the Move Camera.
And there we go.
So now we're interacting
with this map.
In about five minutes we
dropped a Google Map in here,
got the controller, and used it
to animate a change to the map.
WM LELER: That's awesome.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
WM LELER: So not only do we
have Maps now, full Google Maps,
they're really Flutter widgets.
ANDREW BROGDON: Mhm.
WM LELER: And they're really
easy to add and manipulate,
so--
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
You can compose with these.
They're just like
any other widgets.
You can get them in here,
put things over them,
move them around, do
what you need to do.
WM LELER: That's great.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yep.
And so, like I said, if you have
any other questions on this,
check out the
source code itself.
And if you run into any issues
or want any other features,
file an issue request.
WM LELER: OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
All right, so that's Maps.
What else?
What else we got?
WM LELER: Well, I've got
a couple of questions.
Here's a question from India.
We got a lot of
questions from India.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cool.
WM LELER: Probably, I think they
win the award for most number
of questions, which is doubly
amazing because I think it's
after midnight now in India.
So this is pretty amazing.
So the question is, I want to
know what the best laptop is
for developing Flutter apps.
Which are compatible with all
the emulators and so forth?
ANDREW BROGDON: Probably
whatever laptop you have,
right?
WM LELER: That's right.
Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
So, Flutter, part
of being open-- you
know, when the team says
open, they really mean it.
They don't just
mean open source.
It's, you should be able to
use the machine that you have,
use the tools that you already
like, and things like that.
So if you're building Flutter
apps, you can use IDEs.
You know, this is
IntelliJ IDEA that I use.
And VS Code, of course, runs
on just about everything.
So, Windows machine,
Linux machine--
WM LELER: iOS.
ANDREW BROGDON: OS X.
You can run on all of--
WM LELER: [LAUGHS]
No, Apple-- yeah.
They even run on--
you can run this on Chromebooks.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah,
and Chromebook as well.
And so if you're going to
actually build and release
an iOS app, you would actually
need a MacBook or an Apple
machine at that point,
because their toolchain
runs on their machine.
So if you want to actually
build an iBA and sign it,
and do all of
that, at that point
you would need an Apple machine.
But you could even
build it out entirely
without touching a MacBook
or an Apple, you know?
WM LELER: Right.
ANDREW BROGDON: So, yeah.
Really, I mean, it's up to you.
WM LELER: Yeah.
That is one of the
advantages of Flutter,
is that you can actually
build an iOS app not on a Mac.
And then at the last
moment, because of Apple's
requirements, yes, you have
to find a Mac somewhere and do
the release build.
But that's it.
And send it off
to Apple that way.
So, if you have a cousin who has
an Apple laptop, you're fine.
ANDREW BROGDON: Just drop
by, release your app, and--
WM LELER: Yeah, yeah.
Just borrow it for a few
hours, and there you go.
I'm actually going
to switch over.
We have so many live
questions coming in.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: I'm going
to go ahead and do
a couple of live questions.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
WM LELER: One of them is, can I
use a Java library in Flutter?
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
Yeah.
So Flutter has a thing
called platform channels
that can help you with this.
Let me pull it up, and we'll
go into the laptop here.
WM LELER: OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
do platform channels.
See if I can find it
in one stroke here.
There we go.
So, platform channels is
a way for the Dart code
in your Flutter app to talk
to platform code and interact
with native APIs if you want
to, or just use native code.
And so you can set up a method
channel that will marshal data
sort of out of Dart land
and into platform land,
where you can call
Java functions,
you can interact
with the Android API,
or you could work
with hotlink code.
Or on iOS, you could call
into Objective C and Swift,
interact with those
platform APIs.
So if you have a
Java library that you
or your business or your group
has invested a lot of time in,
and it would be a little bit
difficult to rewrite in Dart
natively for Flutter, you can
build a platform channel to it
and use it that way.
You have that ability.
WM LELER: OK.
Let's go to a related question.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: This one,
where is it coming from?
Let me see.
This is coming from Lake Zurich,
which is actually in the United
States, in Illinois, so it's one
of our very few US questions.
So the question is, how
secure is a platform channel?
Is there any chance that
somebody could intercept
that data, especially if
they have a rooted device
or something like that?
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
This is something I was
talking to the engineering
team about the other day.
So the way platform
channels works,
you have in your application--
you have sort of the Flutter
code that's running in Dart.
It's built with Dart, it's
compiled to native code,
and run that way.
And on the side, you
would have some other code
that's running in Android.
You would have the
Java VM that's running.
And on iOS you have your
platform code for iOS
that's also running
outside of that library,
made from the Dart.
And so there's a memory
buffer in your process
for the communication
between the two of them.
But that's within your process.
So there is no IPC, interprocess
communication, required.
Nobody is writing to like a
named file or a named pipe
on the system to talk between
two different processes
where, in theory, somebody
might have a better way
to go in and sniff the traffic
or something like that.
This is all in one process.
So a Flutter app,
in that regard,
is as secure as any
normal Android or iOS app.
WM LELER: OK, so I have another
live question, just came in.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: Can I use a
third-party ad network
in my Flutter project?
ANDREW BROGDON: [LAUGHS] You're
talking to the right person.
Before coming to
the Flutter team
I worked on the Mobile Ads team.
WM LELER: I gave that
one just for you.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
So there is an ad-- there two
ways that you could do this.
One is, you could use
platform channels to interact
with that network's mobile SDK.
So if you wanted to
incorporate the Audience
Network or something
from Oath or InMobi
or something like that,
you could take that SDK,
build a little bridge
using the platform channels
to call methods on it,
and access it and use it
as you would otherwise normally.
The other option that you
have, and I would make sure
that you test this thoroughly,
because it's not something
I've tested personally--
you could use the
Flutter Firebase AdMob
plugin to use AdMob mediation.
So AdMob has mediation,
which is a way
to use multiple ad networks in
concert within a single app,
where AdMob sort of manages
which network shows an ad based
on which one is
providing the most
revenue at that
particular moment.
And because the plugin for
AdMob is using the native AdMob
SDK, the native
Google Mobile Ads SDK,
that is still available to you.
So if you have a
mediated ad unit,
give it a try with that
plugin and see how it goes.
I think it will more
than likely work fine.
WM LELER: OK.
Let me ask another live one.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: Can Dart be a
standalone programming
language?
ANDREW BROGDON: Dart is
a standalone programming
language.
WM LELER: It absolutely is.
Yes.
So, yes, it can.
In fact, it is.
ANDREW BROGDON: I
mean, we-- obviously,
on the Flutter team we
talk about Dart mostly
within the scope of
mobile applications,
because that's
what we use it for.
But, I mean, Dart, Dart for
the web, there's AngularDart.
It's being used
all over the place.
WM LELER: Our own
website, the Pub website,
is using Dart to
build, on the server,
to build a website, as well.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, and
we have Iiro, Iiro Krankaa,
who's actually here.
His inKino application
shares Dart code
in between a mobile
application built
for Flutter and an AngularDart
application as well.
So that's definitely possible.
There's also server-side Dart.
There are people building
server applications with Dart.
So it's a very
portable language.
WM LELER: That's right.
OK.
I think I'm going to ask--
hold on.
Let me find this new
one coming on over here.
Ah.
So we have a couple of questions
that are sort of related.
They're saying, you
know, at one end
of the spectrum is, how do
I get started in Flutter?
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: And we
had one question
that said, I know JavaScript.
Can I learn Flutter and
Dart very easily with it?
And at the other
end of the spectrum,
how do I become an
expert in Flutter?
ANDREW BROGDON: So the two--
how do I get on the path
and how do I get to the end?
WM LELER: I did
that because I just
noticed that Pooja's there.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
Pooja's over there.
Yes.
WM LELER: Pooja, do you
want to come up here?
ANDREW BROGDON: Please.
You would be great
for this question.
Please, come and
join us and sit down.
WM LELER: Join us.
POOJA BHAUMIK: Hi, guys.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
You've got the microphone there.
POOJA BHAUMIK: Hello.
Hi.
ANDREW BROGDON: Hello.
WM LELER: Yeah.
This is Pooja.
POOJA BHAUMIK: Hi.
ANDREW BROGDON: This
is Pooja, everyone.
POOJA BHAUMIK: Hi everyone.
ANDREW BROGDON: And so you
recently wrote an article
about your path from
becoming a complete Flutter
newbie to a more
seasoned coder, right?
POOJA BHAUMIK: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: And so let
me pull that up on my laptop,
actually.
Can you tell us,
for the person who
asked about getting started,
how did you get started?
POOJA BHAUMIK: I
actually got started
because I joined
this company and they
wanted me to work in Flutter,
so I learned Flutter.
And that's how I started.
But I will tell you how
I started with Flutter.
What I did is that I worked
on a lot of designs, you know?
I mean, Flutter is so
great for designing apps.
Well, I wanted to-- let's just
redesign every app that I have,
that I know.
Let's redesign it in Flutter.
WM LELER: That sounds
like a problem, you know?
It's so easy you want
to redo everything.
POOJA BHAUMIK: [LAUGHS]
I wanted to see
if Flutter has the capability
to actually make it possible
for me to redesign all
of my favorite apps.
And I could actually
make apps in one
day, like the entire app in
one day-- all the screens
and everything.
And that's how I was
very sure this is it.
This is what I want to do.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's right.
POOJA BHAUMIK: I
mean, I switched--
I did not switch,
but I did kind of go
from Android to
Flutter because of it,
because it's so amazing
to work with Flutter.
ANDREW BROGDON: And it's
not like those Android
skills aren't used.
You still need them, right?
POOJA BHAUMIK: Yeah,
we still need them.
You can start Flutter
without Android,
but you will have to
come back to Android
at some point or the
other if you want
to work with native channels.
I mean, if you want
to make a fuller app,
you have to know a bit
of Android or maybe iOS.
Whatever you want.
WM LELER: Right.
That definitely helps.
ANDREW BROGDON:
So what were some
of the things that helped you
when you were getting started?
So we talked a little bit
about what you were working on.
Did you look for articles?
Did you look for videos?
Did you look for sample code?
You know, those sorts of things?
POOJA BHAUMIK: I
actually looked--
first I went to the codelabs.
OK, so I checked
out the codelabs.
It was actually very helpful.
I wanted to try out the
Java-to-Dart codelab just
to see how Dart is.
And it's pretty easy, actually.
I learned Dart in a day.
OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: Once you
get past seeing "this"
in a constructor, it's fine.
Right?
POOJA BHAUMIK: Yeah.
Exactly.
It's actually pretty easy.
I don't know.
Other languages, JavaScript or
whatever, they're not so easy.
So, yeah, I was
convinced that day.
And I did try out some articles,
talks by the Google I/O
and Google developers.
ANDREW BROGDON: Flutter.io
docs and codelabs.
POOJA BHAUMIK: Yes.
Uh-huh.
And there are a lot of GitHub
repositories out there,
and a lot of other
tutorials in YouTube.
And they all helped me a lot.
I mean, I'm writing tutorials
on Flutter right now,
so you can check them out
in Medium if you want to.
ANDREW BROGDON: Absolutely.
POOJA BHAUMIK: So, yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
One of the problems we
have, as the DevRel team,
is sometimes it's hard to keep
up with the amount of content
being made by the community.
You know?
That's why our GitHub
repo with samples
actually links out to
a number of samples
that our team didn't
create, we just
think are really,
really good, you know?
POOJA BHAUMIK: Yeah.
You should check out that,
because they have really
accumulated the best
articles and resources that's
possible for you
to learn Flutter.
So check that out.
[LAUGHS]
WM LELER: And it's really great
having people in the community
writing articles.
I remember at one point
where I felt like I
had to write all the articles.
But then it got
to the point where
I was trying to read
all the articles that
were being written.
I've totally given up on that.
There's so much coming out.
POOJA BHAUMIK: Same here.
I mean, in the beginning I used
to read all the articles that
used to come.
Now I think I've
missed out almost 50%.
I mean, it's kind of like you're
all bookmarked, bookmarked,
bookmarked.
I'm like, when I have time,
OK, I'll read them then.
ANDREW BROGDON: So, tell
us a little bit about what
you're working on right now.
POOJA BHAUMIK: So right now,
it's not like a project,
but I am going to
go back to India,
and I'm going to give
a talk at a college
and tell them about Flutter.
Because it's pretty, very, very
required for college people
to actually know about Flutter.
Because you can actually
tell the employees,
but it depends on the
companies, what they're using.
But college students,
they are going
to graduate with that
knowledge, and they
are going to tell other
people to try out Flutter.
So let's target
the colleges first.
As a college student myself, I'm
targeting the college students
in India.
If you are wanting me to
talk about Flutter in any
of the college in India--
yeah.
Hi.
So, yes.
That's what I'm going to work
on now, as soon as I go back
to India.
ANDREW BROGDON: Wonderful.
WM LELER: So I have-- well,
we're almost out of time,
but I have one more
quick question.
So you watched the
keynote, right?
So what was your favorite
thing in the keynote?
POOJA BHAUMIK: The Square.
The Square-- yes.
I mean--
WM LELER: The puzzle?
POOJA BHAUMIK: I
was really shocked.
I was really shocked
that you are just
working with Square right now.
And, yes, also the
two-dimensions thing.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
WM LELER: Yeah.
Yeah.
POOJA BHAUMIK:
Honestly speaking,
this was really
the best keynote,
because every five
minutes I was like, what?
WM LELER: [LAUGHS] Well,
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
They put a lot of
effort into it.
So we're going to move on
to some more questions.
Thank you so much for
sitting down with us.
We really appreciate it.
POOJA BHAUMIK:
Thanks so much, guys.
You're doing a great job.
WM LELER: Thanks for
letting us drag you up here.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
WM LELER: All
right, thanks a lot.
ANDREW BROGDON: There you go.
Right that way.
And take the
microphone with you.
WM LELER: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Excellent.
Thank you so much.
WM LELER: All right.
ANDREW BROGDON: All
right, so we have--
WM LELER: Do you want to do
some livestream questions?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
So we're going to take a
short break in a little while.
And afterwards,
we're going to have
Eric Seidel from the
engineering team, who you just
saw in the keynote.
He's actually going
to sit down with us.
But we have a little more time.
Let's take a few
questions from YouTube.
You want to look
at the livestream?
WM LELER: Yeah, if
you want to do that.
And while you're looking
up some questions on there,
I have a couple more
that have come in.
Actually, here's a good one,
because I can answer this one.
We have a question from
Nebraska, from the US, says,
is there something similar
to build flavors in Android?
And it's true.
You can do build flavors.
It's not really built into it.
But, for example, one of the
developing companies that I
work with is called AppTree.
And all of their stuff,
it comes in flavors.
They actually have
an app which, they
build a flavor for
every single customer.
So you can do--
that's pretty far out.
ANDREW BROGDON: Wow.
WM LELER: And they have--
I don't know, I'm
not even sure I
can say how many
customers they have,
because it's not
public information.
But they build for
places like Stanford
or for companies like
McDonald's, they build an app.
And they have to customize
it for every single customer.
And they do that with flavors.
So you can definitely do that.
And the other thing
that's amazing about what
they do, they not only do that
on Android, they do that on iOS
and they do that
on their web app.
So all three of them.
Because they have
to deliver all three
to every customer,
and they have to have
a separate flavor for it.
So it's definitely
possible to do.
ANDREW BROGDON: They put out
some open-source code, too.
AppTree does, right?
WM LELER: They what?
ANDREW BROGDON: They put
out some open-source code
of various kinds, right?
WM LELER: Yeah.
Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
WM LELER: They've written
a lot of articles.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
WM LELER: I'm not
sure if they've
written an article
about doing flavors yet,
but I should bug them to
write something like that.
ANDREW BROGDON: Maybe we
can talk them into it.
WM LELER: Yeah, I hope so.
Anyway, did you find something?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah,
let's look at this.
So we have some things in here.
And let's take a look at this.
So, when are you planning to
support AR or VR development?
Greetings from the
Dominican Republic.
Hey, cool.
WM LELER: So when
are we going to--
augmented reality and--
ANDREW BROGDON: I
think that one's
a little bit down the road.
WM LELER: I think so, too.
ANDREW BROGDON: I think
there's some other things
sort of before that one.
WM LELER: I mean,
part of the reason
for that is, so far
Flutter is really
concentrating on 2D graphics.
And in order to
do AR, I mean, you
can do it with a certain
amount of 2D graphics,
but it really works
better with 3D
because you do need to
be able to do perspective
and stuff like that.
So I think that's probably
something that will happen.
I'm just not sure when.
It's not on our
roadmap right now.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
see what else we have.
Can I integrate my existing
Android project with Flutter?
WM LELER: Can you?
ANDREW BROGDON: You can.
Many people have done this.
WM LELER: That's true.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
So this is something that's
being worked on right now.
You can go and look at
it, add to an application.
A number of people with
larger applications
have found ways to
integrate a single Flutter
activity into their app.
You can also have a
Flutter activity in Android
that launches a native activity,
you know, platform activity,
to show platform code that way.
And similarly on iOS, you
can have a view control
that is doing Flutter launch
a platform on or vice versa.
WM LELER: And backing
up a little bit,
there's sort of two ways
to go about doing that.
One is, I mean,
the question was,
can you add Flutter to
an existing application?
And you've talked to that.
But actually, another
way to look at it
is that you can actually
convert the entire application
to be a Flutter
application but then
plug in native code from
both platforms into it.
So you can either
do it as, all right,
here's just a piece
of Flutter that we're
going to put in as a single
view, or you can say,
OK, the whole thing is
Flutter, but we're going
to put a lot of native code.
And they're both
good ways to do it.
The latter is actually
easier in some ways,
even though it sounds
like it would be harder.
But it's easier
just because if you
have two separate
applications, like you
have an iOS and an Android app,
and you have to put Flutter
into both of them, you have to
do that in two different ways
and you no longer have a
cross-platform solution.
So you're going to be
modifying two different code
bases at the same time.
Whereas if you go the
other way, the code
that you haven't written
in Flutter stays the same.
But you can just feed that
into a single application.
So both work.
That's probably more
detail than people need.
But anyway--
ANDREW BROGDON: That's OK.
WM LELER: It's definitely
something you can do.
ANDREW BROGDON: For more
information on this,
you can check out the GitHub.
flutter/flutter is
the repo with the SDK.
And you can actually go in
and look at how Add to App
is progressing.
There's a number of
ways that they're
trying to make sure it's
possible, as easy as possible
to mix native with Flutter.
And look for Add to App, and
you can find the code that's
being worked on right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]